here's the problem with the Elf on the
Shelf the first few nights parents have
fun with it right they're on night six
and they're doing the Goldfish where do
you go from there what what's your plan
next it's like you're one up every night
it's more elaborate and then what when
you get to night eight it's you're gonna
have a drop off no you got to keep
getting more but it's it has to end
somewhere but then quickly it becomes a
chore it's like this chore you have to
do every single night my wife now at
night she's like oh man I have to move
the elves again and I'm like no you
don't you don't have to this is not this
is not a a thing we had to add to our
lives you could just not do it we could
be free of
this